大変おまたせ致しました　はじめしゃちょー質問
コーナあぁぁぁーーー！！
ほんとに
おま"たせしましたあ"ぁぁ( ՞ةڼ◔)
２つほど言い訳をさせてください！
一つ目　ﾊｧﾄﾞｯｺｲ！！！！！
＜(　^o^)＞
三)　　)三
＜￣￣＞
ほんとはね
東京にいるときに撮らなきゃいけなかったんですけど
なんせもう東京で動画を撮る気がなくて( ˘•ω•˘ )
どうせだったら静岡に帰ってきてから
質問コーナーちゃんと構えて撮ろうって思ってたんですけど(エライエライ)
まぁ帰って来てから
静岡に帰って来てからもちょっとﾜﾁｬﾜﾁｬすることが多くて
なかなかこう質問コーナーを僕結構
ちゃんと撮りたいんすよ(アップ)
ちゃんと考えなきゃなぁと思ってたら
１１月になっちゃった
大変お待たせしました 待ってた人ごめんね！
静岡で一日ぼーっとしていられる日なんて無いくらい
なんですけど
というわけでちょっとこれ以上皆さんを待たせるわけにもいかないので
やっていこうと思います！
では！
どうぞぉ！
ん？
うわぁ
うわうわうわうわうわ
懐かしいすね
なんなんですか。
いやいや、こっちがなんなんですか。
はっ
ちんちんじぇねぇわ
ウゥーーー
ワァー！( ﾟДﾟ)
ウゥーー
ハーッ！(''Д'')
ダアッ！
ウゥーワ
ダダダダダダダダダダイヒーーｗｗｗｗｗイヒヒヒヒヒｗｗｗｗ
ww ^ڼ◔_∧ڼ◔ｗｗｗ
ww (՞ةڼ◔՞ةڼ◔)՞ةڼ◔(ةڼ◔
ww | ⊃／՞ةڼ◔＿＿ｗｗｗ
w／└─(ةڼ◔＿ةڼ／ｗｗｗｗｗ
ヌベヂョンヌゾジョンベルミッティスモゲロンボョｗｗｗｗｗｗ
ｗ
ダダダダダダダダダ
はｍむむむ(美味い)
バンバンババン
ババババババババババ
バーン！・被害額２万4000円
フィン！
これでいいかい(もう一回お願い)
脳!
大好きです！(知ってた)
ヤりましょう♂
俺、怒られないかなぁ　母ちゃんに
母：もしもし
もしもし
オレオレ
母：おう　オレオレけ？
オレオレ詐欺　　　　└(՞ةڼ◔)」ｷｼｬｱｱｱｱｱｧｧｧ
母：うん
１００万円振り込んでくれ
母：どこへ？
俺の口座に
母：はいはい
あ、ごめん　オレオレ詐欺の動画撮っとるだけ
はい
ピヤァーーー！(☞^o^) ☞Are you キチガイ??wwWwwwWww (☝◞‸◟ ☝)No!! .... ☝( /// ´ิϖ´ิ/// )☝ ﾊﾋｭｰwwwWwww ☜(^o^☜Oh!! You are so キチガイwwwWwwwWww
タッタタラッタ
( ՞ਊ ՞）ｲｷﾞｴｱｱｧｧｧｱｱｱｱ
タッタタラッタヨォドォバァシィカァメェラァｗｗ
タッタタラッタｱﾋﾞﾘｬｽﾓﾝﾄﾞｭｽ( ՞ةڼ◔)☛
タッタタラッタッタ(՞ةڼ◔)先生、トイレ！
High！
タッタタラッタｱﾋﾞﾘｬｽﾓﾝﾄﾞｭｽ( ՞ةڼ◔)☛
タッタタラッタタラタッタッ( ° ʖ °)✧
はじめしゃちょー！
24歳！(仮)
僕昔、半年間6か月
イ↑ギ→リ↓ス→に留学してたんですけど
なんか留学せっかく行ってるのに日本人で固まってるのが一番勿体ないと思うんですよ(固体)
日本人で固まってると喋る言葉も全部
なんかほかの国にいるのに日本語になっちゃうから
英語を喋らざるを得ない状況になって自然と英語を喋っちゃうと思うんで(粉末)
なるべく
友達とかね日本人とつるまずに
まあなんか相談できる相手は一人くらいいていいと
思うんですけど
ほかの国の人と居たら
英語が.. かなり上達するんではないでしょうか
て、いう留学生活が送りたかった..　(　՞ةڼ◔)))　ｺﾞｼｺﾞｼ
きしょいわ(激しく同意)
はいっ
ごめんなさい
髪の毛金か..
考えとくね
いやでも髪の毛そろそろ染めようと思ってるんで
結構ありだと思います
待ってろ
アーッ♂
あぁあぁあああ！
あぁぁぁああああああ！
あぁぁあああ！
はい、正にそれでございます
ここからがまあ本編といっても過言ではないでしょう(半分過ぎてる)
えー、僕の動画のあいさつをずっと何にしようかって考えてたんですけど
非常に難しいでございます(？)
なかなかこうやっぱね難しいあいさつって
ちょっと僕なりに調べてこれいいなって思うのを何個かピックアップしてみたんで
ちょっと見ていきましょう
挨拶決めちゃうとそれをずっと言わなきゃいけないからさ
すっげー考えて遅くなっちゃって申し訳ないっす　　(おい口調)
で？
倍！
惜しいっすね、もうちょっとインパクトが欲しいっすね　(我儘)
あっ
彼とかなかなかいいっすね
おいっ
完全にパクリやないかい(何故いいと言った)
イェイ！じゃねーわ
おいっ！
ありがとうございます
こういう今までの方が良いっていう意見も結構多かったんですよね
没(享年24)
自分でイケメンって言っちゃうか
まあでもシンプルでいいっすね
キラン
あ、全然いいです
ダメだわっ！
あ、違うヤベお金になっちゃった(汚ねえ)
アンパンマン終了のお知らせ
死なないでくれ
採用しないけど(コメ主終了のry
斎藤飛鳥はこんな事言わないよ！
という感じでですね、ちょっと色々他にも
たくさんあったんですけどー
うーん、有り難いですね
とか
あいさつ無くてもいいんじゃないかっていう
コメントもあって
まあ色んな意見があったんですけども..
まあ色々考えました
挨拶決めるとそれをずっと言っていかなきゃ
いけないし
凄い慎重に考えた結果なんですけども
まぁあいさつは...
取りあえずは...
無くていいんじゃないかなっていうﾍﾟｪ〜〜〜〜〜〜〜ﾄﾞﾜﾜｲｺﾞｨﾖｿﾍﾟﾄﾞﾎﾞｺﾞﾜﾝｿｺﾞﾜｿﾄﾞｨﾛｹﾞﾝﾃﾞﾝﾀﾞﾎﾞｨｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗセヴョンイレヴョ〜〜〜〜ンｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
なんか皆あいさつ無いとダメとか
思ってるじゃないですか
俺は別になんか無くてもいいんじゃないかなと思って
ただやっぱ、自分らしさを出していきたいなと
思ってるんで
あの、あいさつは無いにしろ
ちょっとしたオープニングを付けることにしました
しばらく前の動画で何回か使ったと思うんですけども
なんか赤い画面がババって出て
「はじめしゃちょーの日常」って出るやつ
あれをちょっと今後...
まあオープニングっていうか
僕の動画のスタートだよっていう
分かりやすい為に使っていこうかなと思っております
まあ結局僕ЮＴｕｂｅで
どんな動画出していきたいかなっていうと
僕の日常というか
なんかほんと毎日思い付きでやってるような事を
ババアとやってるだけなんで
僕の思いついた事イコール僕の日常なんで
僕の日常を皆さんと一緒に
見ていければいいなと思っているので
日常っぽくなくてもババって
「はじめしゃちょーの日常」って出ると思うんで
まあこれが出たら
あ、はじめしゃちょーの動画のオープニングなんだなと思って見てくれるとありがたいと思います
ほんとに皆さん
たくさんの質問と、えーとあいさつ
下さってありがとうございました(頭打てや)
っとしばらくはこれで頑張っていこうと思います
ほんと遅くなって申し訳ないです
ではまた次の動画でお会いしましょう
じゃあな！
♪